if you're planning on designing or
developing a website before you get
started it's really important to be able
to do
wireframing so that both you and the
client has a good idea
of what it is exactly that you're
building and how it'll work
in this video i wanted to talk a little
bit more about wireframing
what it is how it works and we'll even
build out a wireframe so you guys can
see the full process
and we'll build this example out over
here if you haven't heard of me before
that's fine i'm
adrian from australia i do videos around
design and development and you can check
out my channel in the description below
but without further ado
let's just jump straight into it if you
haven't heard of wireframing before
that's fine what it is is essentially a
visual blueprint for
how the website will work as well as the
pages themselves and it also works
as a schema for the functionality of a
system so that you get a better
representation
of what's going on it's really useful
and it's really easy to do as well
it can take a number of forms you could
just use a piece of paper
and sketch it out or you could use your
ipad or even one of the third-party
websites which
allow you to do wireframing these days
we're going to take a look at a few of
these examples to see how we can build
our own wireframe
but if you want to get started on your
own you can get started with just a
piece of paper
and if you're worried that you're not a
ui designer and
a graphics designer in general and
you're not too sure what's going on well
you don't have to worry about any of
that because wireframing doesn't require
really any understanding
of ui you just need the bare essentials
of being able to draw boxes and circles
we're not going to look into colors
we're not going to look into content or
logos or any of that
wireframing is just the way that the
pages will work
and anyone who's doing design or
development will be able to jump
straight into it so
let's take a look at how we get started
by creating our very first
wireframe in this example i'm going to
be using my ipad and i'm going to be
using an
application called concepts which is
just made for drawing
but i'll put a link in the description
below so that you guys can download it
if that's something you guys want to use
otherwise you can use a pen and paper
just as well
the very first thing i like to do before
i even begin
my wireframing and something that i
think is really important is
creating your sitemap the sitemap gives
your entire website direction so that
you know what pages you're building
and with most site maps the very first
thing that you start off with
is a home page every other page flows
out of that home page so you want to
begin with that
and the very first thing you want to do
is probably write out the
most important pages you have so besides
the home page this is usually things
like the services
page or the product page or the contact
us page
these pages are the core of your website
and if you're doing an application in
this case maybe these are your main
screens that you want to route to
but these are the ones that have sub
pages under them as well
by creating a sitemap just very simply
and visually like this
you'll be able to show and represent how
all the pages work together
if there are some pages you can branch
them out as well
and if some pages are linked to other
sideways you can
draw arrows to represent that in this
example we're going to just start off
with something very simple so
what i want to be able to do is just an
about us page
maybe a features page and a home page
and what we'll do is we'll design these
as wireframes once we draw out the
sitemap and we might even create a
responsive design for them
but to start off with let's create and
finish up this sitemap just to see
what we're going to be creating in this
video today
now that we have the site map done let's
start off with
our very first page and the first page
we usually start on
is the home page the home page usually
represents
the design that we're going to be
utilizing for the rest of the pages
and two of the most important parts of
a home page are the header with its
navigation and menu
as well as its footer because that's
going to exist on most of the other
pages
what we'll start off doing is creating a
layout here for the home page and
usually what i like to do
is create it so it's quite wide we can
zoom into it
and we have enough there for almost 12
columns so that if we want to use things
like bootstrap or
other tools to do the layout they're
ready to go
otherwise we can always do our own
layout for the ui
for the first part of this layout what i
want to be able to do is
create a section here for the logo as
well as the menu
and what you'll do in wireframing
usually is
just create basic representations of
these so in this case i'm just using a
circle with the letter l there to
represent where the logo will go
and for the menu i'm just drawing out a
number of boxes
here with a shaded one representing the
current
one we're on and this will later be
filled out with things like home about
and other sections that we might have
pages for
but it gives us a quick representation
of what the header will look like
after we've finished designing the
header we can start looking at
creating the main hero image and the
hero image these days
are a big gigantic image that sort of
runs behind the very front of the
website as well as
near the header and a lot of the cases
these days you'll find that the menu
actually sits on
top of that header image well sometimes
people like to place it in below
and a lot of these headers as well
sometimes are sliders so what i'm going
to do is
in this example i'm going to draw an
arrow to the left here and
the right and i'm gonna represent this
with a number of dots as well
as the text here to say that this will
be a slider image
and people will be able to slide between
different options here
now that we've done this top header
section with our hero banner we can
start moving on to
the next section here on our home page
and when we're designing a website
usually the next thing that you want to
be able to do
is either a call to action or a bit of
information about
a website and this is really well
represented with maybe an
image a large title and some
descriptions about what the website will
be
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a box here with a crosstalk to
represent where we'll place an image
and we're going to create a title
section here which will have slightly
larger fonts
and a few lines to represent maybe some
description or text will later fill in
in this section now that we've got this
section in and we're going to be
creating
more sections out it's good to be able
to label our sections so that
for anyone coming in from a third point
of view they'll be able to know what
each section is
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to create out
labels for each one of these we'll have
labels here for our menu
for our hero banner and in this case for
our about us section
that way later when we need to reference
it we can point it out and if someone is
coming in they'll be able to identify it
immediately
now let's take a look at creating our
next section over here
and what i want to be able to do is
usually i break them
into line items because sometimes you'll
be able to copy paste them across to
other parts of the website and also
really segregates them but in this case
when you create the website later on
with the ui and the u
um ui design you might not need those
section breaks but now
we'll just create one more here and in
this case i want to create a section
break
here for maybe something like
testimonials or sponsors
in this example for a wireframe we will
have lots of sponsors to identify
so i'm going to represent a nice big box
here that's grayed out
as a maybe h1 or h2 maybe even a h3 tag
here that'll
represent that as sponsors later on and
i'm going to draw a
number of boxes because we'll have about
12 or so sponsors and
each one of these will follow that
similar column design that you would
expect when you're doing bootstrap
or you can fit about 12 columns in a
single section
and with this done we'll be able to fill
out this section quite neatly
and we'll be able to identify it as a
sponsor section
now this is really quick and simple and
you can see that
even the line isn't that accurate and
this is more or less done in just a few
seconds the goal isn't here to have a
perfect ui with perfect box shadows and
backgrounds and colors it's
really just to give a representation of
how you plan the workflow of the website
to be
when you've got that workflow down you
can move sections around you can move
maybe the
sponsor section up or down or to a
different page entirely but the plan
here
is to give a representation of that
section later if
the client come back comes back and they
only want
three sponsors or two sponsors you can
simply update the layout
and maybe provide something different in
that case the other thing i'm going to
do in here is i'm going to add a
button here to our about us section and
this will simply be so
that there is a small call to action
there that if someone wants to learn
more information about that about a
section they can go to there
let's take a look at creating a third
section here
this next section will be our footer
section where we'll finish up the
website design at least here on the home
page
and when you're doing the wireframe for
a footer there's usually a few things
you want to make sure that you add in
there
i think that having the logo reset
and placed in there again sometimes in a
reverse color is a good idea
as well as maybe having a contact form
and a site map
so the first thing here i'm going to do
is i'm going to create a small
contact form which will have a shaded
out title with some inputs and a button
to submit
since we want to show that this footer
will have
a darker color what i want to be able to
do is
show this visually so i'm going to draw
a few lines here
to represent that this might have a
different shade or
maybe it'll have a dark theme or
something different in general just so
that the footer stands out on each one
of the pages
once we've done that the next section
here i'm going to create will
actually be the site map now we don't
have to give the actual pages in here
i'm just going to draw
lines to represent all the pages we
might want to represent
and sometimes you might want to limit
down your site map just to the core
essential pages but
this is just a representation that will
be having that
in there and finally what i like to do
is display the logo here
last and the logo will also have a bit
of information underneath
and usually the last bit of information
i like to include is maybe the
phone number as well as the email
address so that
if someone's looking to contact their
website service or product directly
they'll be able to do that
immediately sometimes it's good to have
this on the header as well but
at least this finishes up our footer
section
and this means that most of our home
page here
is now done and as you can see we've got
our slider image
about us section some sponsors and a
simple footer
i know that some people like to keep
pages for the home page just a single
maybe height and width where you might
not even have any scrolling
whereas other people might have parallax
scrolling that might go
and reach 20 screens in height but
sometimes that's too much so you have to
make sure you balance it out
now since we're doing wireframing one of
the important things
i think is worthwhile doing is labeling
most of the content
content we're working with this labeling
is not really for us but it's more for
the people
viewing this who might not be web
developers so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to select a different color
here in our tools and i'm going to
basically start drawing out arrows to
represent what some of the items here
are
and this will just be visually really
simple sometimes you can do this on a
separate layer so you can hide it later
but i usually like to make it clear and
defined so that if there are any
questions
then they'll be immediately answered by
this labeling
so here i'm going to label that the
contact us form the footer as well as
the business contact information
and i'll work my way up so that if there
are any other things that
might be worth representing like the
phone number and the email address
they'll be really obvious and they'll
stand out
the other thing i like to do is maybe go
through some of the other sections here
as well if we're going to do good
labeling we need to make sure that we
represent what some of these section
legends essentially are so in this case
like the
darker block here will be a title
whereas these small boxes will be
logos of the sponsors themselves and
this just makes it a little bit easier
to read
let's go through our design here and
clearly define each one of these so
in this example this will be an intro
title
and we're going to have some
introduction text here
as well to represent what this
information is
finally let's go through and label this
last image here
on our left and what i want to be able
to do is just show clearly that this
will be an image that will represent the
business
or the information about the business in
a particular way
images are hard things sometimes people
really want to
have the ability to change an image to
fit
what information it's matching and
sometimes they don't even have that so
they use stock photography
and during wireframing it's really not
important which
image you select it's more about
labeling what you'll be doing
and where it'll be laid out and later on
when the client figures out what they
want to do with all the imaging that's
when you can do all of that
finally let's quickly mark up our slider
image in here and just
say that there'll be multiple slides
here so we'll need multiple
images to display this home page and
that finalizes
most of our home page here and now that
we're done with that
i think we can move on to our next
section when
creating websites we do have a number of
different page
layouts and usually what we have is we
have
a internal page maybe a blog page
a contact us page and a features page
and each one of these will have slightly
different layouts and
in this case one of the difficult
layouts to do is actually the features
page
this is the page that really has to
promote your product or your website
so what we usually like to do is we like
to make it a little bit more interesting
with more photos and text and call to
actions to really engage the customer
or the user of the website what i'm
gonna do to
create this page is i'm going to copy
over the header section
we want to keep a consistent header
throughout all our web pages so
in most cases i will be copying this
across
what's going to be different about this
page is that we're not going to have
that very large slider that we had on
the home page
instead we're going to have a title
section here and i'm going to define
this
by creating a separate section in here
and labeling it with the page title with
a darker shade there to represent that
h1 element
this will later on be themed based on
the colors that people might want to use
for the features page but for the time
being we'll just keep it black and white
just so that we know that the title
would be in there
for the features page when we're
creating different sections
we need to really visually represent
those
in this case i want to represent the
features page with
a number of large images and large
blocks of text to really
show off what this product or service
will be defining
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
have a large square box here which will
represent the image
as well as a large title and a
description
and this will be our very first service
in here
in this case sometimes services have
some bullet points
to show off what they do so i'm going to
create some bullet points in here
and each one of those bullet points
might have a tiny little icon or
image as well and this creates our very
first
section here for a feature image but
what's really cool now is that we can
reuse this
to create the next section for our next
feature so what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to just copy over the
layout that i previously used
for the very first feature and i'm going
to copy over the image as well
and in this case i'm going to reuse them
but slightly different i'm going to
actually place them
on opposite sides this will make the
page just
a little bit more interesting without
actually trying to redefine it and it
keeps things consistent as well
now if we have a number of services we
can actually just copy page
copy paste each section down below
once we've done this we'll have a very
simple
representation so that the user will
understand what's going on on this page
let's label this though for someone who
might be viewing this wireframe
we'll show off that this will be feature
one
feature 2 and feature 3. and later on we
can find
images and text to do this but for the
time being
this gives us a clear indication of what
the features page will look like
the only thing that this page is now
missing is the footer
but we can copy that across really
easily so what i'm going to do
is i'm actually just going to grab the
footer here from
our home page and we're going to copy
that across
straight across to our new features page
and we'll be able to copy this across to
all the other pages that we make we
might not need some of that additional
markup that we created there on the home
page because it's a little bit redundant
but what we can do and i can see that is
missing
is maybe a copyright section because
whenever you do have a footer you do
usually have all that information
in there but usually also have a really
small section there for
a copyright so let's actually create
that and that'll be just something
really small on font size which is
usually just a bit smaller than what the
default font size is on a website and
we'll just represent that with a single
line but we'll
mark it up to say that this will be the
copyright
section and let's also copy that across
to
our features page just so that it's
consistent all the way throughout
you'll find that when you're doing
wireframes you can just do this in a few
seconds
and later when you're doing the actual
layout and ui
maybe in adobe xd or figma you can
create out different section components
which you'll really easily be able to
add to other pages
but in this case we'll just do it
quickly and manually
our features page and homepage are now
done but
right now we don't know how we get from
one page to another page
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
just draw out some really large lines
here
to show how you navigate from one page
to another
the first will be here in our header
where we'll design a line to show that
one of the header items will take us to
the features page
and the other will be just in the about
us section where when we select the
button
it'll also take us to the features page
now that we've represented now that
we've represented the navigation
here on our wireframing we can move on
to the next page
the next page i want to create here is
our about us page
and actually maybe no maybe let's try a
different page let's
try doing a contact us page this one
is actually underrated but it's one of
my favorite pages
i know that whenever i'm visiting a
website or a service
and i want to get in contact with them
especially if they're a local near my
area
the contact us page is probably one of
the very first ones i go to because i
just want to give them a call or an
email
so in order to create this let's just
simply copy out
our header here again the contact us
page has usually a number of elements so
the header and the footer are the first
two most basic ones and
since we've designed those already i
usually just copy them across for each
page i do
the other x the other aspects of the
contact us
page i usually like to add in are the um
the phone number the email maybe a
form to represent maybe a contact form
that you might want to simply fill out
as well as a map i think a map is
important especially if your business is
local or your website is doing a local
service
and people need to be able to get to it
so let's copy out a small section here
for our title
like we've done similar to the features
page again so that
it's all consistent and then let's
create some of those other elements so
in this case let's create out a
representation for the map in this case
i'm just going to do it similar to what
i did with the
images on the home page in the features
page where it's just
a large box we do know google maps
usually has a little box at the top
left to represent the address but this
should visualize
that and we should be able to add some
markup here as well
to let people know that this will be a
google map that they'll be able to
actually click to
and get directions straight to this
business
next up let's create this section here
for maybe
the contact us information so in this
case i'm going to do a small little icon
here and maybe this will be like a
font awesome little phone or something
like that with the phone number here
and maybe we'll use another one just
like this with maybe
an envelope to represent the email
address which we can add in the line
below
with these two being the most important
we usually always add them at the very
top
and straight after that some people just
like to send a message through a simple
contact us
form now in this case we already have a
contact us form here on the footer
so sometimes when you don't have those
in the footer you can
add them here to the contact us page but
in this case since
we already have one i think it might be
a little bit redundant to add another
one
but what i might do is just add one in
visually as a representation of what it
should look like if we didn't have one
in the footer
and in this case it'll just be a few
check boxes with maybe a
larger one here which might be a text
area where people can fill it out
with a slightly darker call to action
button which will be the contact form
submit button
and this should finalize our contact us
page
as you can see it's a lot smaller than
our home page in our feature or page but
it's because it's straight to the point
it gives the information that we're
trying to provide here straight away
and in this case let's do some
navigation to show how we'll get to that
contact us
page and in this case it'll just be
selecting the menu at the top right
to make sure that we're browsing
straight there usually sometimes you
also might have
a contact us page somewhere near the
footer but we'll keep it nice and simple
in this case
now that we have our home page and our
features page and our contact us
page done i think this is more or less
most of our content done in general what
we could do is
we could lay out some of our components
here just so it looks visually a little
bit better
if you're doing out wireframes usually
you'll want to do
quite a few pages you want to do
internal pages
category pages maybe product pages and
lots more
and the other thing you want to do is
you want to make sure that you also
create ones which might be responsive
this means that you might want to create
one ready for a tablet or a mobile phone
let's take a look at how we can quickly
do an example
of a mobile responsive design for the
home page
because i think that would be useful
just so that the user or the person
viewing this wireframe gets a
better representation of how the design
adapts
when you go down to a scroll smaller
screen size so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to
put in a label here for mobile version
and what i want to be able to do
is create slightly smaller
a slightly smaller width it'll be what
you would expect for a mobile phone so
it'll probably be
a lot longer than the actual home page
and we'll probably have to add slightly
different elements
in this case the very first element that
we want to do when we're doing
a mobile responsive design is a button
for the menu
and a second button for an interaction
usually
to call the service or business or maybe
to email them or something like that
we'll add the logo in the middle here
because it'll probably be very small
we'll have to make sure it has enough
room and we'll still draw that little
square in the background to represent
the slider image which will be a lot
smaller
sometimes you don't even have sliders on
the mobile version
and you just have a single image let's
put some mock-up here to represent
what each one of these items are and in
this case it'll
just be the mobile button which will
expand out the mobile menu
as well as the phone number or mobile
number depending on what it is
let's draw out an l just there to
represent the logo
and have a look at creating our next
section here
our next section was an intro section
which had an
image it had a title a description and a
button
now since we don't have that same wide
angle that we do on a desktop we really
have to collapse this down to
a single column and row and in this case
what we're going to do is we're going to
rearrange some of the content so it
makes a bit more sense
sometimes people put the image first but
there's no context to that
so what you want to do in this case is
put the title with a description in
first
and then the image can follow this these
will all be
collapsed down to a single column so
that they fit in nicely
and they'll flow on based on the
information that they provide
let's actually copy out an arrow to show
that this is the responsive
version of this same content when we go
to a responsive version we usually make
the
margins from the top to the bottom a bit
smaller as well as the font size and the
image is a bit smaller
so as you can see this section is almost
the same size as the previous section
but obviously this might work
differently in practice it depends on
how you're
arranging the content the next section
here was the sponsor section
and when we're collapsing down this
section since the
sponsors already are quite small we'll
actually be able to fit about
two in on the mobile design if you were
to go up to a larger size maybe a tablet
view or something like that
maybe you could even expand them out to
four or six items per
row but in this case we'll just stick it
in with two items or
in this case maybe three items i don't
know three looks like it's
just barring the edge of what's possible
but at least it doesn't make this
section
too large finally let's take a look at
the last section here which is the
footer and for the footer yes the
contact us form is a little bit in the
way so let's move that out of the way
and let's create out this footer now
since this footer
actually does have quite a lot of
content it's probably going to take up a
lot more space
the very first thing here we'll want to
add in is our contact us form
so let's represent that with a title a
few inputs
a text box and a button and after we
create this
we can move on to the site map and this
will be the next
main column here that we want to provide
and
this column will again have more or less
the same information we could even
copy paste it across and sometimes you
might not even want to have
so many items you might hide out one of
the columns if you don't want to use
them
but in this case i do want to use them
so i'm just going to create this next
section here
as a site map so let's put in a
header section here to represent that
and let's put in a few lines here to
represent the menu items for that site
map
and finally let's create our last
section here
which will be for the logo and the
contact information
so in this case since we're on a mobile
design we
could make the logo here for this footer
section
full width or we could make it half
width and we can create
icons here for the phone number in the
email
and that finalizes our mobile design we
now have our home page with a mobile
version our features page and our
contact us page
and these are the basic building blocks
to create out the rest
of the website what i'm gonna do is put
a
copy of this wireframe as an svg
in the description of this video so you
guys can check it out
i've done lots of wireframes in the past
sometimes
i just simply use a piece of paper and
pen to create them
whereas other times i might create
something in figma or a third-party tool
but the goal here isn't to essentially
use a certain tool to do it
it's more about creating a simple view
for yourself
and the client to present as a plan of
what you're building for your next
website or application
and i might do some videos later on on
ui design
things like color theory and how to
create uis in general
and i hope you guys will check those out
in the future
if you forgot who i am i'm adrian from
australia and i do videos around design
and development
you can check out my channel in the
description below where i do things on
react and wordpress and ui
but otherwise i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did
please hit like hit subscribe leave a
comment and i'll see you in the next one
thank you